and now to the cia
cia offices are trained to lie and to
keep secrets
all in the national interest well a new
book the spymasters
attempts to get at at the heart of the
truth of the cia
and unearth some of those secrets it's
written by chris whipple
cia directors shape history and the
future and chris thank you so much for
joining us
let me start at the very end where you
talk about gina haspel the current
cia director with a quote from someone
saying she'd be a very good
prison camp commandant what did you mean
by that well
you know gina haspel is an absolutely
fascinating character to me
character to me a mystery woman who
flies under the radar
she came out of kentucky a johnny cash
fan and she
cut her teeth as a covert operative in
the back alleys of
africa she then formed a
a relationship her mentor was the
unlikeliest guy you could imagine
jose rodriguez who was the uh
the architect of the whole enhanced
interrogation program
infamously at cia but he became a kind
of feminist mentor to her encouraged her
to go for the
london station as uh at cia and the rest
is history she became
cia director and her record
in my view is really mixed there were
high hopes that she could be the rare
person who could tell donald trump what
he didn't want to hear
but i think she's i think she's really
failed
as the honest broker of information
both to congress and to the american
people
and i can give you many examples of that
but it's very difficult
as we all know for anyone to tell donald
trump hard truths
a recurring theme throughout this book
chris is the importance of the cia
director's relationship with the
president
that's really important how do they all
manage it and how has she managed it do
you think
you know it's uh first of all it's
almost impossible to overstate the
importance of the position of cia
director the cia director is the person
we depend on
to prevent another 911 or lethal
pandemic
and it's almost as you say brian an
impossible
balancing act because you have to tell
the president hard
truths and at the same time you have to
have his ear
the cia director commands an army of
analysts and covert operatives and
paramilitary warriors and lethal drones
but if you don't have a seat at the
table with the president
the whole enterprise is for naught and
this has been true
richard helms for example famously
tried to persuade lbj that the bombing
of north vietnam was
ineffective lbj would have none of it
now fast forward to gina haspel who has
her own difficulties
telling donald trump what he doesn't
want to hear
a question for you chris from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
what is it chris with the cia's
obsession with fidel castro
they've tried to assassinate him they've
tried to invade cuba
what what's up there good question
it had a lot to do with bobby kennedy
one of the
great things about the book was the time
i got to spend
with cynthia helms the widow of the
quintessential cia director richard
helms and cynthia told me and these are
the moments in the book that i love that
where i
really try to humanize the directors
helms would come home
at night and tell her that he had lash
marks on his back
not literally but figuratively because
bobby kennedy had hectored him
all day long about getting rid of fidel
castro
by fair means or foul the kennedys were
obsessed
with that and the other thing that she
told me that i found
just kind of poignant was you know chris
she said they were all asked to do
things they shouldn't have done
and god knows helms was a flawed
character
he did cross the line and he committed
illegal acts for lbj
mh chaos mk ultra all kinds of things
and of course at the end of the day when
the crunch came he stood up to richard
nixon and refused to participate
in the watergate cover-up
and chris you make a good point i think
throughout the book that whatever the ca
has done
and their failures all along their
career their history of the cia
is usually done at the behest of the
president right
that's right and one former director uh
told me brian that there will always be
a cia
you could never abolish it because
presidents would then have no one to
blame
there's a famous lament at langley and
it is in this town there are only
policy successes and intelligence
failures
and of course the cia was blamed for
uh 9 11 but i have chapter and verse in
my chapter
on uh the walk up to 9 11 in which
george tenet and his lieutenants
went over to the white house pounded the
table and told condi rice we had to go
on a war footing now
this was in july of 2001 and yet they
were blamed which is not to say that the
cia hasn't had plenty of screw-ups
and debacles over the years but usually
it's because the president asked them to
do something
all right well chris sipple thank you
very much this is a great book i really
enjoyed it it's a terrific read
once again terrific work for a former
colleague chris whipple thank you so
much
brian great to see you